I have to ask you this this is obviously
a big payday for both of you this is a
very big payday for you this is very
hard to believe it's incredible four
years ago you were on welfare and your
story has brought hope to a lot of
people you actually at one point bought
your dad a boat called one eight eight
what is the name of that boat signified
the one eight eight is what is the
amount that used to collect on the
social welfare so when I got a boat I
named it the one eighty eight after the
amount I used to collect just to always
remind myself of where I came from and
and and what I've achieved you have to
pay respect and pay homage to where you
came from and always remember it you
came from a you came from a tough
neighborhood and I'm wondering if you
could talk to the kids who these kids
Revere you in Dublin that came from your
neighborhood in those projects what
would you say to those kids right now
what would your message be to them
standing where you are today about to
take part in this historic fight if I
was to say anything to them it would
that it would to be to believe in where
you come from
to celebrate your surroundings I think
many people from where I'm from from
Ireland or from anywhere in Europe it's
always or anywhere all over the world
it's almost like you've got to go
somewhere else to achieve greatness or
to achieve a high level I was always
told and I'm continued to be told you
can you you're not going to succeed at a
high level unless you do training in
America or training so you know no Mina
and I I never believed in it I always
felt that that was a weak mind it was
and people fires that run to another
place or another gym it's almost like a
weak mind I always looked around where I
came from believed in my surroundings
believed in the team that I had with me
and rose up alongside them and I believe
that's the true key to success celebrate
your surroundings and rise together all
right
you
you